well are you ready for g2e 2022 the
annual Global Gaming Expo back over at
the Venetian and this year bigger than
ever the convention officially kicks off
tomorrow Madison Kimbrough spoke to some
key players in the industry though about
what the future of gaming could look
like
welcome to g2e 2022 a showcase four that
spans 252
000 square feet a place where gaming
Fanatics to come to see the newest games
like this one from the TV show Let's
Make a Deal
what gaming has always been good at is
bringing people together we have 350
exhibitors small around the world here
showcasing the latest products and
Innovations and so we want to make sure
everyone's got the right opportunity to
do that
let the games begin and what better
place to show off the newest in gaming
technology than here at the 2022 Global
Gaming Expo thanks to an expanded
showroom there is so much more to see
this year and more people seeing it many
International Travelers are attending
this year's Expo after restrictions on
overseas travel led to a decline in
visitors in 2021 so what does the future
of gaming look like Phil O'Shaughnessy
with International game technology says
it's all about going cashless what we're
accustomed to doing going in and getting
a cup of coffee with our phone is now
becoming more and more of the norm in
casinos we just announced with Station
Casinos here in town six of their
properties will offer igt's technology
in cashless gaming sports betting has
also increased in popularity there's
also a huge demand for land base and
digital gaming Game King video poker
ultimate x video poker we were thrilled
today to win the best slot product at
the global gaming awards for our video
poker bar top incorporating sports
betting within it and the showroom floor
opens Tuesday at 10 A.M and runs through
Thursday with registration open
throughout the entire convention
reporting inside of the 2022 Gaming Expo
Madison Kimbrough 8 news now and
according to gaming company IGT while
supply chain issues have risen inflation
on the other hand has not had a negative
impact on their industry so far